hello and welcome I'm James Murphy and today
we're talking about how to exponentiate
efficiently. spoiler alert: this video was
inspired by project Euler's problem number 122.
suppose for a moment that we don't have access
to the built-in exponentiation operator or any
math library that's going to do it for us. put
yourself in the position of someone who might be
trying to write one of those libraries. this is
the kind of thing that you might have to think
about if you were writing a programming language
or a compiler for a programming language. here
i have the most obvious way you could possibly
implement raising something to the 15th power.
namely just start with the variable and multiply
it by itself 14 more times. assuming i didn't
make a typo, if you count the number of stars
you'll see that this requires 14 multiplications,
but you can actually compute x to
the 15th power using far fewer.
the first clever thing that you might think to do
is to use the binary expansion of the number 15.
as we can see from the binary representation,
15 requires 4 powers of 2: 1, 2, 4, and 8. we
can compute those by repeatedly squaring. i
compute x squared is x times x, then x to the
fourth is x squared times x squared, then x to the
eighth is x to the fourth times x to the fourth,
then to get x to the 15th power i
just read off the binary expansion.
i need an x to the eighth, i need an x to the
fourth, i need an x squared, and i need an
x. this allows me to compute x to the 15th power
in only six multiplications. additionally, 15
isn't really special here, i could have done
the same thing using basically any positive
integer. first write it in binary, compute all the
powers of 2 that i need by repeatedly squaring,
and then put those powers of 2 together
according to the number's binary expansion to
get the number. the number of multiplications
needed for this method scales approximately
logarithmically with the size of this number
15. this is much better than the linear number
of multiplications that we use in the naive
method. okay so what's the minimum number of
multiplications that i could possibly get
away with? well for 15 here's the answer:
you compute x squared and then x cubed and then
x to the sixth then 12th then the 15th. however
unlike the binary example, there's no clear
pattern as to how i got these numbers.
well it turns out this is a very hard problem
the best algorithms so far are essentially try
every possible sequence of numbers and see
which ones give you the least multiplications.
there are certainly some tricks that have
been found that allow you to rule out some bad
guesses and things like that, but in general
this is still an exponential time problem.
no one really knows how to do any better. you
might think this is silly, when does anyone
raise something to the 15th power? but people
really do care about this even in real life.
look what happens when i put this
example into compiler explorer.
on the left i write x times x times x 15 times.
on the right you can see both for gcc and clang
that each of these assembly outputs only uses
six multiplications. this isn't a coincidence,
the people who wrote those compilers cared about
this problem. before we dive into the code to try
to find these numbers, first let's note that we
can represent this whole computation process just
with a string of numbers. the numbers are just
the powers and the order that i compute them in.
so for the minimal example i compute x to the one
then x squared then cubed then to the sixth then
twelfth then fifteenth. as you might guess i'm
going to be storing these numbers in a tuple. we
will then successively try all the possibilities
what can we make in one multiplication in two
multiplications in three multiplications and
so on. because in the process of computing the
most efficient way to exponentiate for some power
i'll also compute a whole bunch of other powers,
i'm going to represent and store all the
information that i compute during the algorithm.
i will store all that information inside a class
which i can then ask to compute more and more and
more until it finds the numbers that i'm looking
for. i'll start with an initial chain of just 1
meaning x to the first power. i don't need to do
any computations to get x to the first power. this
map will keep track of for each number what is a
minimal length chain that ends up at that number.
so when i plug in 15 i should get this chain,
or at least one that's the same length. every
time i multiply n plus one things together i first
multiply n things together, so i know that when i
compute the next step of the algorithm i'm going
to use the answers from the previous step. for
that reason i'll use this variable cached chains
to store the answers from the previous step. the
step variable tells me what step of the algorithm
i'm in, how many multiplications am i using.
and the step limit just tells me not to go too far
so i don't run out of memory computing. a single
step is definitely the hard part of the algorithm.
first i check that i haven't stepped too far and
then i increase the step count. i iterate through
all the chains of one less length and for each of
them i need to compute what are all the new chains
of one more length that i can make from them.
this corresponds to multiplying two smaller powers
that we've already computed. for instance for this
chain i could add on an 18 by using 6 and 12 or
a 21 by using 6 and 15. you might think that for
a given chain in order to extend it i need to
try all possible pairs of elements in the chain
but it turns out that for exponents smaller than
this it's always okay to assume that one of the
numbers is the largest number in the list. it is
by no means obvious that assuming this will still
give you the right answer. i'm not going to even
try to explain why this is allowed, but i will
link to a good starting point, a research paper
that you can read if you want to look into it.
okay so i will always assume that one of the
two powers that i'm using is the biggest one.
that is the last thing in the list. for the other
one i just try all the other things in the list.
then i compute the exponent that i get
by using those two smaller exponents.
i make a new chain that has now one more thing
on the end of it, and then i add that to my set
of newly computed chains. now the important part.
if this is the first time i have ever seen this
exponent, then i set this chain as the minimal
chain for that exponent. i use the built-in
dictionary method set default to do this. what
set default does is if a key already exists in
a dictionary it does nothing. but if it doesn't
exist in the dictionary then it sets the value.
this ensures that each number is linked to
the first chain that produces that number,
subsequent or longer chains will not overwrite
this value. the last thing that we need to do
is set all the chains that we just computed
to be the new cache for the next step.
then we make a little helper function which will
facilitate finding the answer for a specific
exponent. basically we just keep computing longer
and longer chains until the set default finally
finds a chain that is able to produce the desired
number. then to find a chain for a specific
exponent we just step until it's computed and then
return it. if for some reason we only cared about
the number of multiplications and not the actual
chain that tells us how to get there, then we can
just note that the number of multiplications is
one less than the length of the chain. so here's
how you would put it together to solve the project
euler question, which asks us to compute the sum
of the first 300 answers. i'll time my answer to
make sure it doesn't take more than one minute.
i set the end that i'm looking for as the number
300 then i create an instance of my class. just
for my benefit i want to print out all the chains
and then for project euler i'll just go ahead and
sum up the answers. let's see how it goes. okay
it looks like we finished with an answer of 2593
in 51 seconds. scrolling up towards the top
here we do see that it found the same answer
that i mentioned before for 15: 1 2 3 6 12 15.
also notice that it's not a monotonic function,
sometimes a bigger exponent
can take less multiplications.
the last thing that i want to mention is that
although we did this problem for multiplication of
just integers we can actually say the exact same
thing of multiplication of any kind of objects.
as long as i know what it means to multiply a
thing by itself i can make sense of exponentiating
something or raising it to an integer power.
this allows the answer to be useful in a more
general context beyond just what you would
get for integers. for integers after all
when's the last time you ever raised something
to a power other than two three or maybe four?
imagine for a moment that x is not an integer
but a one million by one million matrix.
saving even just one multiplication might be
meaningful when you have a problem this large.
i also want to point out that there are many
matrix models that are useful in applications.
you start out with a vector and then repeatedly
multiply by a matrix to get the next state in
the model. that means if you want to know what
happens a thousand time steps later in the future,
that's equivalent to multiplying by
the matrix to the power one thousand.
this is another place where taking
a big power of an object comes up.
well that's all i've got on this topic, if you
enjoyed the video please consider subscribing and
telling your friends, and as always don't forget
to slap that like button an odd number of times